call of duty season 4 features new
operators weapons
zombies maps and more if you're excited
for what's in store
drop a like and share some hype with us
in the comments okay
here's everything we know let's kick it
off with the story
season 4 picks up in a south african cia
ground station
where we meet jackal this friendly face
is here on behalf of stitch his mission
is to deorbit
some cia satellites doing so will let
perseus continue
with their mind controlling test
subjects in verdansk
speaking of verdansk once these
satellite paths are corrupted
they fall out of orbit and land across
parts of verdansk and of course
the satellite map from cold war's
multiplayer adler and some new faces are
sent to recover a data recorder from the
crash site
but adler secretly keeps it to himself
this brings us to war zone new points of
interest this season
are the fallen satellite areas this
includes a limited time event called
ground fall
which is basically another series of
challenges to complete
doing so will unlock specially themed
calling cards charms
xp and a special blueprint for a
secondary weapon for completing
all the challenges also coming soon is
the red door event
they're only hinting so much at this
point so we'll have more details as they
come
it looks like they may work as some sort
of strange mental teleportation device
like they do in the campaign
but who knows the old gulag gets another
facelift
this season it's modeled after the
hijack map that's right
hijacked is coming to cold war the
motorbike is coming to war zone as well
as some more game modes like resurgence
mini
on vergansk this mode is just like the
rebirth island version
with no gulag and a max player count of
45.
later in the season we will also see a
new payload mode
40 players fight to deliver a payload
through a series of checkpoints
and can easily be stopped by other
squads in the process
moving on to new operators three will be
unlocked throughout the season
beginning with jackal the mercenary from
the cinematic who works for stitch
and clearly loves his job next is salah
who we see teaming up with adler
he's working with nato to take down
perseus and has a background in
counter-terrorism
and hostage negotiation not much else is
listed in his bio but here's hoping
we'll learn more later
last but not least is gregory weaver
from zombies
he's rocking his classic black ops 1
gear and even has his bloody eye patch
to match
next up are season 4's weapons the mg82
is an all-new lmg unlocked with a battle
pass at level 15.
next for the assault rifle category we
have the c58
a fully auto ar with a slower rate of
fire
but with the fast bullet velocity and
high damage at close range
for smgs this season we have the caparis
coming back from black ops 1.
oh excuse me it's called the ots 9 now
like before it's got a fast rate of fire
with high recoil
so it's perfect for close quarters a
mace melee weapon is coming
and lastly the nail gun makes its return
to the black ops series
oh boy four new maps are coming to cold
war this season
collateral a large oil drilling facility
for 6v6
and 12v12 amsterdam a small rooftop map
for 2v2 and special game modes
and two classic maps make their return
rush the small paintball map from black
ops 2
and as mentioned before hijacked
everyone's favorite luxury battleground
at sea
moving further into cold war's
multiplayer some new game modes are
coming including the returning one in
the chamber
capture the flag and a new multi-team
mode called sat link
in satlink you and your squad hold down
satellite points for as long as you can
10 of these points can be found across
the map and it's score based so the
longer you hold out the more points you
get
lastly for multiplayer news the hand
cannon returns as a kill streak
zombies get some big updates this season
including a new zoo location and
outbreak
and a new round based zombies map
malware der toten later in the season
they're not saying much in the blog post
about this map just yet
so stay tuned to gamespot for the latest
also the new map collateral will be
coming to onslaught
as well as a new game mode called
onslaught accelerated
rounding up the news the new prestige
icons have dropped
and you can now gift the battle pass to
a friend
aww if you're excited for season 4 and
enjoy the video
drop a like and subscribe gamespot's
play for all this year is full of
exclusive interviews and announcements
to celebrate the e3 season
and our love for all things gaming see
you next time
you